I definitely consider myself internet
famous at this point I think I I think
the difference between famous and
internet famous it's a dividing line
that is getting a little fuzzier really
month by month at this point at not just
for me but I think as our culture
changes you know and I think it's about
the medium that you are famous in you
know if you are if you are famous for
being on television you are reaching a
much larger and broader audience than
anyone who's on the internet you know as
as popular has as certain ideas and
people have become on the internet you
know they don't really reach that kind
of super Fame that's sort of global
broad appeal until they move into
television you know you can look at
anything like Twitter for example you
know that was that was the thing that I
heard about through somebody else signed
up for and started using nobody cared
about it you know I was explaining it to
my friends and they thought I was crazy
and then and then you started to see you
know people people on the internet got
excited about it and started using it
and so it was sort of an internet thing
and then you started to see people
talking about it all the time on
television I was a very quick
transformation it was very very very
quick but it moved into that medium and
that's the point when it became a really
famous thing and it's it's a thing that
almost everybody knows about now even
though maybe they don't understand it
frequently when it's mentioned it's
accompanied by a lame joke about how
it's weird or stupid or whatever so you
know in many ways it's it's infamous
outside of the internet rather than
being famous but you know for me for me
my fame is very targeted you know it's
it's not local because it doesn't have
anything to do with physical space but
its local on the map of ideas and taste
you know because it's it's a i right I'm
I'm
famous on the internet for writing a
certain kind of song and that appeals to
a certain kind of person who's
interested in certain things and you
know within a certain community I'm I'm
pretty well known but you know just
walking walking down the street here in
New York nobody knows who I am you know
I'm rarely rarely recognized in public
and so it's in many ways it's the best
of both worlds because I have a I have a
fan base that is large and loyal enough
to support me and I get that that ego
boost that is you know I I know now is
kind of critical to me you know that
feedback from people telling me that
they like this song or that song that
they really enjoyed this concert or that
CD you know I get that I get that back
and forth but at the same time you know
I can see how having that kind of
relationship with the entire world would
be kind of unpleasant you know you think
about somebody like poor Michael Jackson
you know who couldn't who can't really
go out in public anymore well now he's
dead but when he was alive he could not
go out in public anymore and you know I
think that's it's a bizarre it's a
bizarre thing that the the people that
we love the most we sort of forced them
to become shut-ins we sort of cut them
off from the rest of the world you know
it's a strange strange thing that Fame
does
there are a couple of things that play
that that govern what kinds of ideas
become internet famous one of them is
just the fact that there are more geeks
on the internet than there are non geeks
on the internet and this is just because
the internet is it is still a relatively
new medium on this planet so you know I
think a lot has been made about a lot
has been made of the ascendance of geek
culture and you know you'd be crazy if
you didn't think a lot of that had to do
with the fact that there is the internet
and now all these people who use
computers have a way to use their
computers to get together in different
ways to communicate and create things
and disseminate ideas and bounce them
off and one another and change ideas so
you know I think part of it is just is
just the the Internet is the perfect
medium for for geeks because it's like
computers and that's mostly where the
Internet is you know but aside from that
I do think the common thread that that a
lot of internet culture shares is a a
kind of hyper post-modernism I barely
know what I'm talking about here so so
bear with me but you know I think
there's a kind of there's a kind of
humor in particular that is unique to
the internet and it has to do with
referencing other things in an ironic
way and reimagine ating reimagine ating
reimagining them in a certain way and
recycling ideas of course this is part
of you know what what post modernism
means but I think there's another sort
of winky aspect to the things that
become really popular in internet
culture that sort of sits on top of that
standard post modernism you know collage
combination of different Thea's I mean
you look at look at lolcatz for example
which is bizarre
our and could only exist on the internet
and as a i think a real a real good
measuring device for determining if
somebody is part of internet culture or
not you know i mean they're basically
pictures of funny pictures of cats with
a caption you know and so you can say
well that's that's dumb that's you know
there are lots of greeting cards that
are like that we've had that for a long
time but there's a there's a
self-referential quality too low cats
and a certain you know you can it's a if
the language that cats speak somehow
it's this kind of pidgin language that
cat speak and you can it kind of makes
sense I mean if you're a fan of low cats
you the reason you like it is because
you see you see a caption and a funny
picture and yes you are looking at a
funny caption of a funny cat picture but
also there's a joke there it's very hard
to explain what that joke is to somebody
who doesn't get it and it happen has to
do with that language that cat speak
that is made up that somehow a very
large group of strangers all seems to
agree that this is the language that
can't speak and so I sound like a
lunatic just talking about it and that
is I think a perfect example of the
things that become popular on the on the
internet and and why even though I
haven't really said why because I don't
even know why
I yes I walk a dangerous line between
comedy and non comedy music like like
many who have come before me i'm not i'm
not the first to do it and it's it's a
it's a troubling thing sometimes to be
known as the guy who writes funny songs
when in actuality my favorite songs are
the ones that are not funny at all my
favorite songs of mine are the very sad
ones and and so yeah you know I I think
it is I think it is crazy I have learned
that it is crazy for any artist to
decide how they want to be what kind of
artist they want to be known as you
don't get to decide that the best case
scenario for you if you were an artist
is to make the things that you love to
make the things that you want to make
and to have a group of fans who like it
and support you and and who make it
possible for you to continue making more
stuff that's all you can that's all you
can ask for and you know I think if you
if you start to worry about you know are
people gonna think of me as a novelty
musician when when really I'm I'm a
sensitive writer of important songs then
you know that that way lies madness
because it's not up to you to decide and
there's little you can do to change
anyone's mind once you put the stuff out
there that is yours people will make of
it what they will and you're lucky to be
even thinking about trying to change
that so shut up yep that's kind of its
kind of what I think about that so I'm
just so I'm just so pleased to to be
here and you know I feel for full so I
soup i feel i feel so fortunate to be
making a living this way that you know
i'm i'm i'm happy for the fans who think
of me as a novelty musician and i'm
happy for the fans who think of me as a
writer of important songs however you
like me I'm just glad that you like me